so you talked about japanese food being
really good but i i think like the la
food culture is also like really good
right yeah i think one of the best parts
about living in l.a is like you want
like indian food you can get really good
indian food you want japanese food you
want like chinese food like you're so
it's so diverse yeah yeah yeah someone
who specializes in like each cuisine was
the british food though
what beans on toast
was fish fish and chips i want you to
bring up british food with michael he
will [ __ ] on it
i'm so sorry he just hates british food
i'll keep her like i'll i'll go to him
and i'll be like really serious about it
and i'll be like oh please but have you
had a testimony
then you haven't had proper british food
for you to mention british food to my
god
he's made fun of you jellied eels that's
not a thing yeah but that's like that's
low-hanging fruit yeah that is
low-hanging he says that you guys like
colonize india with spices but the best
you think you could think of is beans on
toast like he just ships
constantly i'm like have you ever been
to britain he's like no
have you
no
why not
i've been to uh
and the only place in europe i've been
to germany that's it
no no no it's just like some sponsor
thing i don't remember i did not like
that
still water i had to pay for it i kept
asking sparkly sparkling water just
tastes like spicy water to me i don't
like it
yeah you have to specify like tap water
tap water yeah no i kept paying like
three euros oh my god
i think i did last day i just stayed in
my hotel and ordered room service
oh uk's fun i do want to visit uk i
think it's
one of the places i want to visit
eventually yeah do you think i could get
away with an accident
[Music]
like beans and toast yeah oh i love
beans and bees and toast
you sound like uh like you got rejected
for a crown audition
what is this i'm rooting for the part of
uh queen elizabeth uh oh yes i know it's
on toast people actually eat beans on
toast yes yeah people do eat beans
literally like my growing up obviously
because it's really easy to make you
just
dude the [ __ ] breakfast food at the
hotel it's just nothing but beans
sausages and beans on toast
i mean like do you have beans on taste
by itself or
so
yeah sometimes you would have that but
it normally always came with cheese on
top yeah you would so my mum would
always make it like maybe like once a
week it would always be like beans toast
cheese and then a fried egg on top and
then you put brownies that sounds good
yeah and that's [ __ ] good yeah that's
that's i love that normally i have beans
on toast with like a full full english
breakfast yeah you get the full english
stuff and then yeah
tomatoes yeah tomatoes hash browns
and liverwurst
deliver first do you like black pudding
pudding
my parents bought me mcdonald's
breakfast
honestly i i [ __ ] with mcdonald's
breakfast i love mcdonald's it's so
[ __ ] good cakes are perfect
their pancakes are perfectly circular
it's perfect now i am like against
eating pancakes thank you thank you i
don't think it's a breakfast like not
it's cake yeah it is it's cake it's it's
like americans have tricked each other
into eating dessert for breakfast
turtles yeah i like them all my griddles
are so good it's like a pancake by this
bun
chicken mcgriddle i just feel like you
have a a pancake obsession i love
pancakes do you like ihope
yeah i hops ruined pancakes they are
kind of mid honestly what would you say
is a place that has good pancakes then
like pancake specialty restaurants you
could probably yelp and look it up like
oscars pancake bar or something like
that
so you have it for breakfast or just
like any time i'm an adult i can eat it
any time i want
but i drink like i really like the
standard like a bowl of rice some soup
maybe like some grilled fish or meat egg
kimchi i don't know that's like a good
breakfast to me yeah yeah oh i thought
you had that with pancake i was like
that's a
that's a lot of carbs
yeah it is very carb heavy like pancakes
waffles like cereal it's all sugar and
soda for you i can't believe we
normalized that growing up like i can't
believe that was normal what
pancakes for breakfast yeah i know yeah
it's weird that's that's that's what
that's what i'm trying to say that's
what we're trying to say yeah i like
bread bread for breakfast is pretty good
you're very european yeah but it's just
pancakes are a little bit different
pancakes are sweet yeah yeah the syrup
like savory bread is great like just
some toast or just
rip it apart eat some of it i love it i
just don't even know what i'm so hungry
now i'm gonna shouldn't have said that
yeah holy crap i'm hungry yeah luckily
i'm not a breakfast person like
breakfast is the meal i probably eat the
least uh because i don't know some like
i i feel like a full english or
something is [ __ ] great and then
american breakfast is great as well but
it's just like so heavy especially like
japanese breakfast when you go to like a
ryokan and you have like a proper
japanese breakfast
it's like a three-course meal
yeah yeah yeah it's too much it's cheap
but also english breakfast are too much
i remember like day three of mcn and i
was having the breakfast uh the hotel
breakfast yeah and it was like a full
plate of like make your own english
breakfast dude by like 12 p.m i'm so
sick because it's so like it's so oily
yeah yeah yeah yeah and it's a lot of
oil in the morning
yeah it's like when you've had
everything like like a long day of
drinking and then the next day you're
like i get amazing hangover food yeah it
is
it's like it's like that's that's why
it's a british breakfast right yeah
perfect hangover food but like you eat
every day and it's just way too heavy
it's so ugh yeah i mean i do like miso
soup in the morning though that is like
this is just yeah you can't go wrong
with it
okay like that's it though i only need
miso soup i don't need anything else
just one miso soup
maybe like a small bowl of rice do you
know uh tonjiru do you know that it's
like it's miso soup with like pork and
like veggies oh but that sounds like a
pork broth
what's your favorite food to eat when
you go to japan sushi sushi okay okay
yeah i remember two like when i went to
a poke the first time and i like this
underground subway whatever we're hungry
i'm like oh there's a sushi place let's
just go there yeah go there eat it's
omakase and i'm like this is so good
like it's just like a random
hole-in-the-wall place that we sat down
and yeah
no like sushi is [ __ ] incredible in
japan because of course it is right but
like i even i i like even think like the
cheap conveyor belt
those are my favorite actually because i
love like you know the omakase set and
everything like that but like
i want to just sometimes you just want
to [ __ ] stuff yourself with like good
sushi and like
even though you're just playing like a
dollar for like the conveyor belt sushi
it's better than like slapstick it's
better than most places you can find
abroad honestly
because i remember you guys are telling
me about like the horror stories of
british sushi
i'm sorry what
no no no no no no
no it's not
her royal majesty's spam
that's [ __ ] hawaii
black pudding sushi yeah now what was
the uh was it yo sushi is that that oh
that's [ __ ] that was the worst one in
an abomination
something like british and like sushi
shouldn't like no no no no it should
have been but sometimes in america
there's good sushi here too yeah
sometimes i just really want like a
deep-fried california roll topped with
like baked salmon and like drizzled with
three different i feel like that's not
even sushi though like one like i feel
like they're both different types of
sushi but i like i like bubbles yeah i
like both yeah yeah that's really good i
i personally don't count that as sushi
but like i won't say no to a california
yeah
because
[ __ ]
now well these these dudes try to train
like 15 years to slap rice around yeah
like they're not they're not going to
put like avocado on it no but it's
delicious like cream cheese
yes okay yeah but like again i don't
count that as sushi it's it's a good
meal but like yeah actually i think it's
kind of like it's like an american taste
no i have seen one place that sells
california roles yeah because like 99 of
sushi places you go to don't even do
roles you know it's like roles just like
don't really exist in japan like cut
like maki i guess yeah yeah yeah that's
that's like the closest you're going to
get oh god i'm so excited to eat food
there i am so hungry right now sushi is
like my favorite food of all time all
right going to japan is like i'm just
going to eat sushi every single day
every day and you're never going to get
bored of it because you never know i
actually won't i thought i would buy
like like sushi is the one japanese meal
where i ate sushi before moving to japan
and i ate it more after moving japan and
just like have not got bored of it
that's
aside from sushi is there anything else
you like about japanese food like do you
write ramen oh okay i like instant ramen
more than regular ramen
places i can i can i can admit that you
could say maybe ramen's too heavy
normally yeah it's too much but saying
it's better i like the taste i like the
taste i don't think you've been to a
good romance
in l.a i go to a ramen place right and
it looks good and i'm like can i have an
extra egg please and they're like oh
that'll be three dollars and i'm like
can i have like why are you speaking in
bridges
three dollars three dollars
can i have like like seaweed and you're
like oh yeah that's dollar fifty they
gave me like one type
why aren't all the toppings so expensive
bro yeah but does it taste good but does
it taste good it's good but it's just
like i i think instant ramen it fits my
palette more i don't know i think you
need to go to like a proper good ramen
place in japan have you tried superman
that's the best one that is pretty good
yeah but there's nothing like you know
it's like 1am you're sad as [ __ ] you
bring out the pot you open the shin ram
in black you know
luckily you know the japanese ramen
stores are open like 24 7. normally oh
yeah yeah because you guys are there
those places are open until like 4 a.m
yeah you go there yeah
ramen in japan and i do remember it
being very delicious so maybe it's been
like so long
is it because it's not spicy enough in
japan um
shin ram is like pretty spicy so
is korean ramen yeah
yeah i did order like non-spicy so maybe
that's fine yeah there's a lot of places
to do spicy ramen i will try that next
time maybe you should go to the place
like corner and i went to what's it
called oh no no okay never mind that was
like the saddest ramen scottish hot
hottest scottish scottish
fries
the accent sorry you just pour whiskey
into it
[Music]
that's just pancakes i mean you love
pancakes right i love pancakes no you
guys don't rate okonomiyaki okay i i
think it's okay i didn't think it was
bad i just think it's okay i just i will
not accept it's the jiu-jitsu of [ __ ]
japanese foods okay joey what do you
think about you guys okay it's okay he
thinks it's okay i really like it i
really like it as well yeah oh [ __ ]
hell
well you also haven't watched arcane so
i'm unsure
should we take that back then you're
associating with the bad tape